I could have a lever and try and push up
a car and I'd have to just keep going as
many times as I can but the longer the
lever is the more Force it's going to
push on the other side yes I have to be
willing to push the lever up and down
but the length of the lever is going to
be a far greater determinant on how much
strength the force is on the other side
of that thing you have to be able to
work but after you know how to work it's
about what work you do and so the
equation for output of whatever it is
whether it's muscle whether it's money
whether it's relationships whatever it
is the equation is volume of input times
leverage equals output